Transcription: Mandy Vincent
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Comment faire disparaître
une femme de l’Histoire ?
C’est un sujet
qui me touche personnellement.
Comme homme,
comme historien,
comme directeur de musée.
Parce que vous l’avouerez quand même,
depuis les débuts de l’humanité,
hommes et femmes
sont paritaires sur cette planète.
Et pourtant, l’essentiel
de l’histoire qu’on raconte,
c’est celle des hommes, des mâles,
souvent racontée par des historiens,
mâles eux aussi.
Et dans ce contexte-là,
j’ai envie de vous montrer
comment le processus se met en place.
Et pour ce faire,
j’ai choisi de vous raconter
une histoire qui se passe ici,
mais vraiment ici,
à cent mètres de l’endroit d’où je parle,
pour une partie de cette histoire.
À un kilomètre de l’endroit d’où je parle
pour une autre partie de cette histoire.
Et la troisième partie, à Paris.
Dès lors, je vais vous présenter
un rappel de cette histoire
pour ceux qui ne la connaîtraient pas,
en trois chapitres, à la Balzac.
Premier chapitre,
où un Roméo de Jaun rencontre
une Juliette de Bulle.
(Rires)
On est en 1786 et un gars,
Pierre, Jacques, Jean, appelons-le Jacob,
était au service militaire.
Il servait
dans un de ces contingents capitulés
où on ne leur demandait pas trop
de gré ou de force s’ils voulaient
y aller, ils devaient y aller.
Il a fait quelques années de service.
Notre Jacob a 29 ans, et puis il revient.
Il revient ici en Gruyères
et il cherche du boulot.
Sa passion, c'est l'élevage,
les vaches, les bovins.
Seulement, le problème
est qu’il est de Jaun,
il n’a pas d’argent, il n’a aucune terre.
Il ne lui reste qu’une seule possibilité
pour sa passion de l’élevage bovin,
c’est domestique de ferme.
Il cherche donc du boulot
et il en trouve à un kilomètre d’ici,
ferme de la Buchille,
chez la famille Magnin
où on l’engage comme domestique.
Il fait parfaitement l'affaire.
Joseph Magnin en est enchanté
et tout se passe pour le mieux
dans le meilleur des mondes.
Voici la maison où il va être engagé.
Il se retrouve donc dans cette ferme
et là, dans la famille Magnin,
il rencontre la fille Magnin.
Une fille magnifique
qui s’appelle Marie-Françoise.
Ils tombent immédiatement amoureux
l’un de l’autre au premier regard.
C’est l’amour fou, l’amour vache.
Ils ne peuvent plus
se passer l’un de l’autre.
C'est un monde incroyable,
un conte de fées.
Malheureusement,
il y a les parents Magnin.
Et ce type, vacher, sans terres,
sans argent, ça ne va pas.
La fille Magnin est la fille
des fermiers des von der Weid
et ces derniers sont toujours
sur la ferme avec les armoiries.
Et c’est sur ces pavés qu’ils se sont
aimés puisque la ferme n’a pas bougé.
Donc Françoise et Jacob se retrouvent
en conflit avec la famille Magnin.
Or, arrive une nouvelle,
on cherche un vacher pour aller à Paris.
Alors là, les Magnin
font intervenir tout le réseau
et on se dit « Jacob à Paris,
Paris, c’est beau et c’est loin. »
Surtout en 1787.
Et on en est donc débarrassé, c’est sûr.
Deuxième chapitre,
où loin des yeux, loin du cœur
est un proverbe qui va être démenti.
Jacob arrive à Paris,
on l’appelle Jacques.
On parisienne son nom,
Boschung devient Bosson
et Jacques Bosson entre au service
d’un domaine tout à fait particulier,
à Paris, le domaine de Montreuil.
Le domaine de Montreuil
est un domaine assez particulier.
C’est Madame Elisabeth de France,
la sœur de Louis XVI,
qui a mis en place une ferme modèle.
Vous savez, les nobles au XVIIIᵉ
n’ont pas grand-chose à faire,
si ce n’est d’imaginer
de grands projets agronomiques
et c’est ce qu’elle a un peu voulu.
Et donc, dans ce sens-là,
elle a créé une ferme modèle.
Il va y travailler, il y est reçu
et il travaille tellement bien
qu’en un an,
il devient l’intendant
du domaine de Montreuil.
Et tenez-vous bien, ce vacher,
arrivé un an auparavant,
rencontre Madame Élisabeth,
sœur de Louis XVI, tous les jours.
La preuve, elle écrit
dans sa correspondance :
« Jacques vient m’apporter
ma crème tous les jours. »
(Rires)
Notre Jacques va s’épancher
sur ses sentiments,
il va dire qu’il est malheureux
et il sait que Françoise l’est aussi.
Et là, ordre de Madame de France,
il faut faire venir Françoise à Paris.
Les von der Weid interviennent,
le père Magnin, Joseph, est décédé.
La mère Magnin doit bien accepter.
Jacques reçoit Françoise à Paris
et à son arrivée,
on décide de les marier
en justes noces le 26 mai 1789.
Jacob, devenu Jacques,
Boschung, devenu Bosson,
épouse Françoise Magnin dans
l’église Saint-Symphorien de Versailles.
Devant toute la cour.
La mariée porte une robe
extraordinaire offerte par la cour.
Cette robe est absolument magnifique.
Et on chante une petite chanson.
On fredonne un air qui a été
composé par madame de Travanet,
la dame de compagnie
d’Elizabeth de France.
Cette chanson, c’est :« Pauvre Jacques,
quand j’étais près de toi,
je ne sentais pas ma misère.
Maintenant que je suis loin de toi,
je manque de tout sur la Terre. »
Tout Paris fredonne,
cette mélodie est partout,
à la cour mais aussi
dans les rues de Paris.
On fredonne :
♫ Pauvre Jacques, ♫
♫ quand j’étais loin de toi,
je ne sentais pas ma misère. ♫
♫ Mais à présent que tu es près de moi,
je manque de tout sur la Terre. ♫
♫ Je manque de tout sur la Terre. ♫
Vous aurez inversé l’ordre
de ce que j’ai chanté.
(Rires)
Donc, tout va pour le mieux
dans le meilleur des mondes.
Françoise est enceinte.
Elle attend une fille
qui va naître en 1790,
qui s’appelle Marguerite.
Madame Elisabeth écrit
dans sa correspondance :
« Madame Jacques est grosse
et toutes mes vaches aussi. »
(Rires)
Troisième chapitre,
où la belle Françoise est bien plus
à plaindre que le pauvre Jacques.
C’est la Révolution.
Ce sont les troupes
de la Révolution, de 1790 à 1792.
Tout bascule dans le désordre.
Jacques doit partir comme soldat
dans les troupes républicaines.
Il fait une période de service
dans la Garde nationale.
Françoise continue à s’occuper
de Marguerite sur le domaine de Montreuil.
Mais plus on avance dans le temps,
plus on commence à prendre en grippe
tous ceux qui ont
soutenu la famille royale.
Sortant de son service,
Jacques embarque sa fille Marguerite,
la robe de mariée, quelques objets,
et rentre en Suisse
alors que Françoise est arrêtée
au moment de partir avec son mari.
Elle est emprisonnée.
Elle fait un an de prison
dans les prisons de la Terreur,
la pire période de la Révolution.
Elle ne doit la vie sauve
qu’à la disgrâce de Robespierre.
Robespierre tombe,
on gracie ceux qui avaient été condamnés
sous la période précédente
et Françoise est libre.
Elle est à Paris.
Son mari est à Bulle,
sa fille est à Bulle.
Elle va donc partir de Paris,
faire le trajet dans une France dévastée
pour retrouver son mari, ici, à Bulle.
Ils s’installent dans une ferme
à cent mètres de l’endroit
où nous sommes ce soir.
Et là, ils vivent heureux,
ayant eu un enfant.
Ils vivent heureux jusqu’en 1835,
pour Jacques, qui décède,
et en 1855, pour Françoise.
Devant l’église de Bulle,
vous trouvez la plaque mortuaire
de Jacques et Françoise.
Elle a été longtemps placée
contre le mur de l’église,
puis elle a disparu
au fil d’une restauration.
Elle s'y retrouve depuis 2018.
Venons-en maintenant à comment
faire disparaître une femme de l’Histoire
en prenant pour illustration
ce que je viens de vous raconter.
D’abord, vous avez le seul portrait
du Pauvre Jacques.
C’est une miniature d’à peu
près sept centimètres de diamètre
qui date de la fin du XVIIIᵉ-début XIXᵉ,
d’un portraitiste qui s’appelle Leroy.
C'est le seul portrait que nous ayons.
Si vous le regardez bien,
autour du médaillon,
il y a un cercle dessiné.
Il était prévu de coller
les cheveux du Pauvre Jacques
et d’en faire un reliquaire.
Si vous regardez bien le portrait,
vous voyez qu’il y a un feuillet
qui porte l’image de l’homme
mais que le deuxième,
complètement caché,
on n’y voit que les rimes de la chanson
que je vous ai fredonnée tout à l’heure.
C'est la page qui renvoie à Françoise.
Et le clou qui agrafe les deux feuillets
symbolise la passion, l’amour.
Première façon de faire disparaître
une femme de l’Histoire,
c’est de donner un visage à l’homme
et de faire de la femme,
une femme sans tête.
Deuxième façon de faire disparaître
une femme de l’Histoire,
c’est de continuer à faire vivre
le nom du mari, Pauvre Jacques,
à travers une mémoire sur le long terme.
En Gruyères, on chante très souvent
« Pauvre Jacques » à quatre voix mixtes.
La partie solistique qui est censée
être les paroles de Françoise
est prise en charge par un ténor.
Sans tête, c’est aussi
une femme sans voix.
On continue à faire vivre
le nom de Pauvre Jacques
à travers toute une série d’éléments.
Je vous en ai mis ici un exemple,
les grands magasins « Au Pauvre Jacques »
qui seront une chaîne de grands magasins
qui durera
jusque dans les années 1930 en France.
Troisième façon de faire disparaître
une femme de l’Histoire.
Les noms et les lieux entretiennent
la mémoire des gens.
Si vous prenez le Géoportail
du canton de Fribourg
et que vous allez voir Bulle,
vous allez trouver
un chemin Pauvre Jacques,
un chemin de la Buchille, nom de la ferme
où ils se sont rencontrés.
Mais vous pouvez chercher à Bulle, à Riaz
à Marsens, village d’origine des Magnin,
vous ne trouverez pas une rue,
un sentier, ce que vous voulez
qui s’appelle rue, sentier,
Françoise Bosson Magnin.
Enfin, la dernière façon d’effacer
les femmes de l’Histoire,
c’est d’utiliser les objets
qui leur ont appartenu
pour les faire disparaître
dans leur fonction.
Au Musée gruérien, en 2020,
on a fait de l’ordre dans nos réserves
et on est tombé sur un ensemble
d’habits liturgiques pour curés.
L’habit était en mauvais état.
On s’est dit :
« Faisons une restauration. »
On a donc contacté un atelier
de restauratrice, madame Dubuis,
qui nous a envoyé un rapport très précis.
L’étoffe est de la fin du XVIIIᵉ siècle.
Elle est en soie extrêmement précieuse.
Le taffetas est en soie.
Les nœuds utilisés pour faire
le tissu sont extrêmement précieux.
Le seul exempl
qu’elle connaisse est à Florence,
au musée des Offices,
et de plus, ce tissu était
très à la mode à la fin du XVIIIᵉ siècle.
Or, on racontait,
dans une histoire orale non vérifiée,
que la robe de mariée de Françoise Bosson,
en revenant à Bulles,
avait été transformée en habit liturgique.
Depuis le confinement en 2020,
on a la preuve,
l’histoire racontée et la réalité
que ce qu’il reste devant vous est la
robe de mariée de Françoise Bosson.
Une façon presque diabolique
de faire disparaître
les femmes de l’Histoire.
Dès lors, mon épilogue
qui tient en quelques mots,
c’est de dire que tout ça ne va pas.
Nous devons tous prendre conscience
que cette humanité a été construite
par les hommes et les femmes
de façon paritaire
et qu’aujourd’hui,
on doit faire sortir les femmes
des limites de l’Histoire,
des marges dans lesquelles
on les a enfermées.
On doit transgresser ces limites.
On doit leur donner la place
entière qu’elles méritent
dans la perception des faits historiques.
Ça, c’est pour nous,
les hommes, en particulier,
et, vous les femmes, continuez
à réclamer votre présence dans l’Histoire
parce que, comme le dit si bien
la devise du Musée gruérien,
je vous le rappelle,
mesdames et messieurs,
« Le soleil brille pour tous. »
(Applaudissements)